[Musique]
bienvenue sur TV 78 toute cette semaine
nous allons remonter le fil des
meilleurs moments de notre émission le 7
8 c'est votre émission qui vous relais
l'actualité vous donne des infos
pratiques et vous donne aussi des idées
de sortie à faire dans les Yvelines
premier numéro de ce best of consacré au
premier jour du mois d'octobre vous
souvenez à sans doute des longues files
d'attentes devant les stations d'essence
oui ce début du mois a été marqué par la
pénurie de carburant on évoquera aussi
la politique avec une élection
législative partielle dans les Yvelines
celle de Jean-Noël Barrault et les
confidences et d'Aurore berger sur son
rôle de présidente du groupe Renaissance
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est parti pour
ce best of du 7 8
[Musique]
bonsoir Mathilde bonsoir Nicolas vous
êtes Paris pour cette nouvelle tranche
d'informations
en tout cas ce week-end justement on
jette tout de suite un coup d'œil au
programme de ce 10 octobre
dès que interminable et des heures
d'attentes sans savoir si oui ou non il
restera suffisamment de carburant pour
sa voiture ce week-end une station sur
deux était fermée car non approvisionné
la grève dans les raffineries est
d'ailleurs reconduite le préfet des
Yvelines a également interdit la vente
et l'achat de l'essence dans les bidons
les jerricanes ce lundi encore la
pénurie continue dans les stations
services c'est 30% d'après le
gouvernement des stations qui sont
impactées comme de nombreux Français
nous avons besoin d'essence pour aller
travailler nous allons voir comment ça
se passe autour de Guyancourt dans les
Yvelines
les Yvelines font partie des territoires
les plus touchés par la pénurie comme
pour 10 autres départements la
préfecture a pris des mesures pour
éviter la pénurie complète parmi elles
l'interdiction du remplissage de
jerrican on vient tout juste de
s'arrêter à la station de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux comme vous pouvez
le voir derrière moi la file ne
désemplie pas depuis le début de la
matinée les stocks de sans plomb 98 sont
déjà à sec en raison d'une distribution
partielle depuis quelques jours elle a
une de l'actualité également c'est cette
législative partielle élection
législative partielle avec le résultat
du second tour dans la deuxième
circonscription et Jean-Noël barreau
l'emporte largement oui hier soir le
ministre délégué au numérique a été élu
à
71,67% dans la deuxième circonscription
des Yvelines face à la candidat de la
nupes m'a été cariffe bedouani déjà au
gouvernement il va passer la main à sa
suppléante Anne bergante mais le grand
gagnant de cette élection reste
l'abstention seulement 26,17% des
votants se sont passer aux urnes ça
n'est pas vraiment une surprise puisque
dans des élections législatives
partielles on tourne toujours à peu près
autour de 25% de participation donc on
est un petit peu en deçà donc ça n'est
pas vraiment une surprise on n'a pas
l'effet moteur que peut avoir une
élection nationale on était les seuls à
voter en fait en France pendant ces deux
derniers week-end
ça pose évidemment la question de
l'écart peut-être qui grandit aussi
entre les électeurs et nous et toute la
question de savoir comment on peut
ramener les jeunes dans les débats
publics et leur donner envie en votant
mais pas que en participant à la vie
la vie civile elle est politique
en général de pouvoir s'investir
néanmoins hormis cette abstention
effectivement on peut dire qu'on nous
avons été largement élus avec Jean-Noël
Barraud donc les résultats des urnes ne
portent pas à discussion en ce qui
concerne le fait que ce sera moi qui
siègera effectivement la suppléante je
suis toujours un petit peu étonnée de
l'interrogation puisque en fait au mois
de juin c'était le cas de beaucoup de
ministres qui se représentaient en
législatif et ça me posait visiblement
pas de question j'ai demandé ma
disponibilité alors vous vous le savez
sans doute c'est qu'il y a un délai de
carence là qui s'applique donc je ne
suis pas aujourd'hui député je serai
député dans 30 jours et j'ai demandé ma
mise en disponibilité c'est une chance
que j'ai de pouvoir le faire mais je
voilà je travaille encore jusqu'au bout
dans dans
cette hôpital à Paris quotidiennement
vous serez député la date du 10 novembre
c'est pour ça que dans la présentation
ne soyez pas étonné pour les
téléspectateurs c'est bien marqué futur
député des Yvelines acrobates clown
magicien je ne parle pas des talents
cachés de Nicolas dandry mais bien du
20e Festival International du Cirque des
Mureaux il a encore battu des records ce
weekend Nicolas vous vouliez réagir oui
parce que je le dès le début de la
saison vous carburez aux bonnes blagues
Grégory non mais c'est histoire de
mettre une bonne ambiance sur ce plateau
j'ai 170 députés donc 169 autour de moi
avec moi et donc il faut évidemment
porter un collectif ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire définir des lignes des objets
politiques qu'on a envie à un moment de
porter dans le débat public ça définit
qui on est et puis j'oublie pas le
territoire évidemment elle se divine et
donc je continue à arpenter tous les
week-ends
premier rendez-vous la réunion avec les
groupes modèles et horizons qui
composent la majorité présidentielle un
rendez-vous inter-groupe effectué une
fois par mois objectif assurer la
cohésion de la majorité tout en laissant
des marges de manœuvre individuelles aux
députés c'est pas la caserne encore une
fois d'être dans un groupe politique
c'est un choix d'appartenir un groupe
politique c'est un choix d'appartenir à
un collectif et moi ma responsabilité
c'est d'animer le collectif c'est quoi
la ligne qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire moi
je dis voilà ce que je recommande après
chacun est libre parce qu'à la fin
chacun est jugé individuellement aussi
en tant que député et chacun a été élu
individuellement en tant que député pour
occuper cette nouvelle fonction comme la
une de la première victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron affiché dans son bureau Aurore
Berger a osé en général dans la vie
qu'elle soit je pense qu'à un moment il
faut pas attendre qu'on vous donne les
choses il faut y aller il faut oser
prendre la parole il faut oser
s'exprimer il faut aussi avoir de la
cohérence dans les positions qui sont
les mots dans les propositions que vous
portez moi je suis très fière que la
première proposition de loi de mon
groupe ce soit sur la garantie de
l'accès à l'IVG pour toutes les femmes
et je crois que s'ils m'ont choisi c'est
parce que peut-être j'avais de
l'expérience du précédent mandat que
j'avais la personnalité qui est la
mienne ou ils savent que je peux aller
au combat pour eux que je peux aller au
combat dans l'hémicycle mais que je peux
aussi aller au combat pour obtenir
vis-à-vis du gouvernement un certain
nombre de choses la situation n'a pas
changé la grève a été reconduite ce
mardi chez Total et certaines autres
stations services en fin entre midi la
première ministre Elisabeth borne a tout
de même annoncé la réquisition des
personnels des dépôts des sauts exon
mobile pour mettre fin à la pénurie la
préfecture des Yvelines à quant à elle
accordait ce matin un accès prioritaire
aux stations essence à certains
professionnels notamment les
professionnels de la santé pour vous
aider on vous rappelle qu'on a mis en
place sur les réseaux sociaux Facebook
et Twitter de la chaîne une publication
interactive où vous pouvez retrouver et
partager des informations en temps réel
sur les stations essence des Yvelines
bon plan si vous êtes comment un petit
peu allergique au pollen j'ai découvert
une application qui s'appelle live
pollen disponible sur tous les
téléphones et en fait elle donne
l'information des mesures du pollen en
temps réel et à proximité il me semble
qu'il y a une voiture un véhicule qui
permet de détecter la radioactivité
d'une ou de plusieurs personnes est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
tout à fait donc un véhicule d'anthropo
gammamétrie en langage un petit peu
compliqué c'est des véhicules qui
permettent de mesurer la contamination
interne des personnes soit en situation
normale pour du suivi de travailleur par
exemple soit en situation accidentelle
si d'aventure on devait avoir à
contrôler la population civile ou des
intervenants sur le site et à ce moment
là on peut détecter assez rapidement les
niveaux de contamination de ces
personnes contamination interne puisque
c'est facile d'accéder c'est plus facile
d'accéder à la contamination externe en
revanche une fois qu'elle est ingée on
pense notamment à l'iode à ce moment-là
c'est plus compliqué mais donc le but de
ce camion c'est de fournir un résultat
pour évaluer la dose engagée de ces
personnes et alors si vous détectez
quelqu'un ce week-end comment ça se
passe alors normalement ça ne devrait
pas arriver mais à ce moment là il sera
pris en charge évidemment comme comme
tout examen qui est réalisé dans ce
camion il est pris en charge par un
médecin en quelques clics des
algorithmes prouvent que cette image est
falsifiée parmi eux celui créé par une
jeune yvelinoise Tina nicuka et
doctorante en mathématiques appliquées
le but de ma recherche c'est de créer
des algorithmes qui donc sont capables
de savoir ce qui est arrivé à une image
et donc dans détecter les anomalies donc
c'est une je sais qu'elle a subi telle
opération parce que l'image subit une
suite d'opérations mathématique si je
sais qu'elle a subi telle opération
particulière je peux voir localement
dans l'image s'il y a des parties qui
n'ont pas subi la même opération on a
programmation généralement elle est elle
est comment dire aller sur trois axes
bien sûr l'axe culturel donc avec la
dédicace avec
l'accueil des comment dire des auteurs
toutes les animations qu'on peut avoir
aussi autour de la thématique BD mais
aussi un axe je dirais pédagogique
social on va utiliser cet outil comme
c'est le cas de du dans le reportage
combien de voix où l'on va essayer de
l'utiliser en fait
la BD comme un outil pour aller vers des
publics qu'on dit empêcher ou qui n'ont
pas
et donc avec l'idée bien sûr de de
reprendre confiance de vivre une
expérience unique c'est vraiment des
retrouvailles il y a pas de performance
artistique en soi et puis petit à petit
on se rend compte que les gens en fait
comment ça s'ouvrir et à démontrer en
fait leur capacités parce qu'on a tous
des capacités que ce soit les enfants
les jeunes les adultes le tout c'est
d'aller les chercher et avec le bon
moyen
[Musique]
on continue de feuilleter cet album du
mois d'octobre retour notamment sur
l'université des mairies de l'Ouest
parisien et sur la visite de Brigitte
Macron s'était à Poissy nous terminerons
cette émission par un grand moment
d'émotion vécu au Vélodrome national de
50 ans en Yvelines
[Musique]
alors c'est l'occasion de rencontrer
d'abord de rencontrer les maires
d'autres communes pour partager mais
c'est aussi parce qu'on a des on a des
thématiques qui nous sont communes avec
des experts et on peut échanger on peut
venir chercher des idées nouvelles on
peut partager des idées et puis on peut
aussi recevoir un prix c'est ce que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui et oui le prix de
l'innovation pour la cité éducative qui
va
se porte quand on l'espère septembre
2025 2025 Catherine Vautrin qui est la
présidente de l'enrue c'est l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine est
venu justement hier c'était le 11
octobre dans les Yvelines dans deux
communes chantent les vignes et les
Mureaux et Les Mureaux commune on
pourrait dire qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
couleurs politiques mais au fond les
problèmes sur les mêmes sont les mêmes
c'est des communes de cette grande
vallée de la Seine qui ont eu les
constructions très importantes pour
accueillir les populations entre autres
de l'industrie automobile et c'est
Poissy chant Les Mureaux Mantes-la-Jolie
voilà c'est c'est en fait les mêmes
populations ça a été les mêmes histoires
c'est les mêmes populations c'est la
même volonté de de faire évoluer nos
villes de normaliser nos villes de
redonner du cadre de vie de la qualité
de vie à nos habitants et de refaire de
la mixité aussi parce que notre but
notre but ça n'est pas que de faire de
l'urbain notre but est d'accompagner
avec tout un tas de processus et
dispositifs originaux le plus originaux
possible les habitants entre autres les
enfants parce que c'est aussi les
habitants de notre territoire à être des
vrais citoyens et à réussir avec leur
propre compétences faire de l'urbain
c'est aussi refaire de la ville sur la
ville et puis c'est aussi donner au à
toute habitant donc il soit la capacité
d'avoir un parcours résidentiel ça c'est
très important il faut pas que les gens
soient enfermés dans un lieu il faut
qu'on leur donne les occasions de
choisir là où ils veulent vivre
l'ensemble de notre projet de
renouvellement urbains sont tous les
vignes et il est effectivement la cité
éducative c'est quoi la cité éducative
c'est l'endroit où l'ensemble des
acteurs qui accompagnent l'enfant dans
son évolution peuvent porter le projet
ensemble ça veut dire quoi en gros c'est
ici nous sommes tous acteurs de
l'éducation vous les enseignants vous
les animateurs du périscolaire vous les
associations qui accompagnaient l'enfant
hors temps scolaire mais surtout vous
les parents qui êtes le premier
éducateur et vous les enfants parce que
vous avez selon votre HD des choses à
dire et comment on peut et nous on
travaille depuis le début 2019 sur un on
est accompagné on travaille sur un
projet pour que les acteurs travaillent
ensemble chez nous ces acteurs que je
viens de vous citer ils ont travaillé
ensemble pour dire quelle était la
lecture de l'école de demain selon eux
l'école complètement mutualisée où on
partageait tout on partageait tous les
projets notre lecture donc leur lecture
s'est transformé en en cahier des
charges qu'on a remis aux architectes
pour en faire un concours d'architecte
et maintenant les architectes qui ont
été retenus sont en train de créer
l'objet dans lequel c'est l'ensemble de
ces acteurs vont fabriquer leurs projets
et comment en fait ça se fait avec des
constructions reconstruction de cette
petite éducative qu'on pourrait comparer
à un campus et en gros c'est la
maternelle l'élémentaire le collège le
périscolaire la bibliothèque médiathèque
La Maison des Parents et comment en fait
ça se construit sur un endroit où on
démolit des écoles il y avait ce temps
intermédiaire qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait utiliser et ce terme
intermédiaire on a décidé de nous de
construire ce qu'on appelle la cité
Champeaux c'est un c'est un lieu unique
construit en moins de 10 mois avec des
conceptions extrêmement nouvelles dans
le dans l'architecture qui est vraiment
l'incubateur et actuellement dans cette
cité Champo qu'on a ouvert au début de
l'année il y a tous les enfants de cette
école qui vont après retrouver ce grand
campus qui vivent ensemble avec
l'ensemble de leurs éducateurs ce c'est
vraiment cette incubateur du grand
projet cité éducative les maires de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sont retenus
réunies il y a une une semaine à l'hôtel
de l'agglomération pour évoquer les
difficultés budgétaires de leur commune
l'objectif c'était de faire prendre
conscience de la situation financière
difficile des collectivités
territoriales comme vous l'avez dit par
rapport à la baisse des dotations de
l'État et puis avec la conjoncture
actuelle de la crise énergétique écoutez
pour la ville de Montigny par exemple
sur 70 équipements publics j'en ai 40
qu'on considérait enfin concernés par le
décrétaire Sierre j'en ai un là que je
vais refaire c'est le gymnase Pierre de
Coubertin un gymnase c'est 9 millions
d'euros minimum de travaux 40 bâtiments
à refaire si je le fais tout seul avec
les diminutions de notation de l'État et
bien je n'y arriverai pas les
conséquences de cette inflation sur le
budget des classes sous bois par exemple
c'est à peu près 1,5 millions d'euros à
trouver pour l'an prochain 1,5 millions
d'euros c'est à minima 15%
d'augmentation des impôts le sujet de
l'automobile financière dont on a
entendu parler l'autonomie financière
des collectivités mais les élus
demandent aussi la mise en place d'un
bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie un
accompagnement financé sur les travaux
d'isolation thermique des équipements
public demandez par l’état toutes les
danses ce n'est pas forcément aux
journalistes au début on a fait une
classe préparatoire littéraire ensemble
parce que des sujets variés nous
intéressait et après ça s'est fait un
petit peu naturellement justement cette
idée de pouvoir toucher à tout apprendre
un peu tous les jours rencontrer des
gens et pouvoir informer voilà et puis
avec
l'actualité qui est très chaude
également en ce moment bah forcément on
a voilà on a pris on prend plaisir à
toujours creuser cette actualité et
c'est également ça que que demande le
métier de journaliste
sur le tard plutôt Nicolas c'est bon les
présenter nos invités nos étudiants vous
pouvez poser votre question justement on
a parlé de nos expériences nos premières
expériences vous est-ce que aujourd'hui
il y a une personnalité qui vous a
marqué de la voir d'échanger peut-être
avec elle personnalité politique
alors nous on a fait une interview en
live d'un gendarme sur le sur le stand
de la gendarmerie et au milieu de
l'interview est arrivé Gérard Larcher
donc ça a été aussi impressionnant de
devoir gérer le cadrage etc de voir
arriver ça de personnalité qu'on avait
vu que sur les plateaux
télés
impressionnant au-delà de ça ça nous a
aussi vraiment on a ça nous a montré que
voilà le journaliste va être un caméléon
devrait devait vraiment devoir s'adapter
et être aussi très polyvalent donc on a
vraiment été confronté à ça et ça a été
ça a été un réel plaisir d'un gendarme
c'est l'occasion de repréciser que c'est
c'est vrai que c'est un rendez-vous pour
les élus mais c'est aussi pour
rencontrer justement tous leurs
partenaire des professionnels des
entreprises des institutions qui a été
présentes aujourd'hui sur ces pyramides
du Port-Marly pour ses universités des
mairies vous avez parlé de l'interview
d'un agenda vous avez croisé aussi
Gérard Larcher qu'est-ce que vous avez
pu faire d'autre aujourd'hui sur sur
cette journée alors pendant la première
partie de la matinée on a vous avez pris
en charge par Mickaël qui nous a
vraiment formé
pour la pour la caméra donc il nous a
appris à au cadrage du cadrage et puis
la deuxième partie de la fin la deuxième
partie de la journée pendant
l'après-midi on a été beaucoup plus
autonome beaucoup plus libre mais la
nuit nous a indiqué quelques directives
et puis après on a pu aller interviewer
des élus des maires et c'était aussi un
plaisir oui on sait que vous Grégory
votre rêve c'est une interview avec John
Luigi Buffon le grand gardien de
football italien est-ce que vous vous
avez un rêve une personnalité que vous
souhaitez que vous souhaitez une
interviewer et révèle m'a dit secrète
Nicolas Landry mais bon oui est-ce que
il y a peut-être un aboutissement pour
vous dans cette carrière peut-être une
personnalité un événement peut-être un
événement un sujet que vous rêveriez
traités moi je pense que au-delà des
interviews ce que j'aimerais c'est
pouvoir découvrir aussi d'autres pays
par journaliste et pouvoir couvrir un
peu plus l'actualité internationale
au-delà de une personne en particulier
aussi
la découverte à travers à travers le
journaliste
pour vous ce soir moi je voudrais
vraiment remercier je pense au nom de
nous deux on voudrait remercier l'équipe
TV 78 et puis Michael et Mélanie qui ont
vraiment enfin les remercier pour leur
bienveillance et puis les conseils
précieux qui nous ont donné pendant
toute cette journée un grand merci mais
merci à vous merci à vous Enza merci
Solène on découvrira votre travail
notamment demain on diffusera un
reportage sur ces universités des
mairies de l'Ouest parisien on peut le
découvrir d'ores et déjà également sur
les réseaux de sociaux de TV 78 merci et
bravo et bah bonne suite dans votre dans
vos études dans votre carrière merci de
après trois défaites le FC Versailles
Renaud avec la victoire il s'est imposé
2 à 1 face au mangue grâce à une superbe
frappe de à la 22e et un but de prunier
à la 27e minute le FC Versailles fait un
bon dans le classement en se retrouvant
sur le podium à seulement trois petits
points de Concarneau et Dunkerque
Céline hier vous avez parlé d'une
signature inversée vous souvenez du
joueur qui a signé à Versailles la
petite colle comment s'appelle-t-il j'en
ai aucune idée de la petite conne en
direct Mathieu Dossevi en 6e
professionnel et qui est d'ailleurs
passé par le manque à signé à Versailles
Versailles qui a enregistré l'arrivée de
nombreux renfort et d'anciens joueurs
professionnels on peut citer aussi gérer
même lands pardon pour pour cette petite
voilà pour voilà c'est je suis expert du
foot c'est facile peut-être que vous
pourrez me poser une petite colle tout à
l'heure dans le cadre d'Octobre Rose
Brigitte Macron était à Poissy ce
mercredi 12 octobre pour visiter la
maison les trois arches ce centre
d'accompagnement au cancer a pour
objectif de soutenir les patients et les
proches touchés par la maladie depuis
son ouverture en 2021 la maison a
accueilli 110 personnes tous les
patients que j'ai rencontrés me disent
tous que ça va mieux
que ça participe tout à fait aussi à
leur guérison donc il y a aussi une
rassurance que le patient peut avoir
parce qu'il comprend tous ces symptômes
qu'il a autour de la maladie ici il ou
elle va comprendre ce qui se passe non
seulement il va comprendre mais il va
partager avec d'autres parce que on ne
peut se comprendre
contre contre patient constitué de trois
pôles informations soin oncologiques et
mieux être la maison les trois arches
permet aux femmes qui souffrent ou ont
souffert du cancer du sein de se
retrouver pour des ateliers on explique
aux patient quels sont les
recommandations nutritionnelles pour
éviter les récidives comment s'alimenter
aussi pendant les traitements par
exemple pendant la chimiothérapie la
radiothérapie il y a beaucoup d'effets
secondaires indésirables de la fatigue
ils ont pas toujours
l'énergie l'envie de se nourrir nous
participons à l'atelier retour un emploi
un cycle de 5 ateliers qui permet
justement personnes sous contrat de
travail en arrêt de pouvoir avoir un
espace pour poser toutes leurs questions
leurs interrogations sur le retour en
emploi est-ce que ça va être possible
dans quel dans quelles conditions ce
genre de structure et peu connu en fait
des femmes qui ont cancer du sein et en
fait elles n'ont tout dit vraiment ça
leur a permis de pouvoir rencontrer
d'autres femmes qui souffrent de cette
maladie de ce cancer et du coup les ça
les aide en fait de parler elles se
comprennent mieux
rencontre
pluridisciplinaire c'est à dire que ça
touche vraiment tous les aspects or soin
médicaux purement fait à l'hôpital là
c'est complètement ça les accompagne
dans même la réinsertion l'emploi le
sport savoir prendre soin de soi c'est
vraiment il y a tous les domaines et ça
c'est c'est très agréable pour elle
finalement sur Brigitte Macron même si
elle est la première dame la femme du
président de la République a été plutôt
abordable c'était plutôt facile de lui
poser des questions très accessible elle
a parlé à tout le monde elle a même fait
des petites blagues non elle était
accessible c'était très émouvant aussi à
certains moments prenait vraiment le
temps de discuter et d'apprendre à les
connaître aussi c'est vrai que plusieurs
femmes du coup on pleurait suite à sa
visite d'émotion quoi c'était un moment
fort j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à accepter
voilà je m'attendais pas du tout à ça en
fait
je franchement non je pour moi c'était
une visite de contrôle même s'il y avait
quelque chose je pensais que c'était
autre chose et quand on a diagnostiqué
qu'on m'a parlé qu'on m'a dit le mot
cancer je me suis vraiment effondrée
vraiment et ça a été très très dur pour
moi oui je me suis isolée je me suis
isolée même du corps médical il fallait
que il fallait que je reprenne confiance
en moi il fallait que je comprenne ce
qui se passe voilà ça a été vraiment un
tremblement de terre pour moi vraiment
alors comment c'est fait le lien avec
les trois arches parce qu'on a bien
compris que l'objectif de cette rupture
de une structure c'est d'accompagner les
personnes qui sont qui sont malades
comment vous avez connu les trois arches
comment commencer c'est fait le lien
justement et que avec la structure
alors en fait
pour de pas reprendre le travail la fin
de la chimio et donc j'ai passé des mois
et des mois à ne rien faire à rester sur
le canapé à ne rien faire et ne pas
savoir ce que j'allais faire par la
suite parce que j'étais fatiguée et je
n'avais pas le moral mais je me suis dit
bah le seul moyen c'est de reprendre le
travail donc je suis allé voir mon
médecin traitant pensant pouvoir
reprendre le travail et je me suis
effondrée je veux dire en fait j'en suis
pas capable il m'a donné les coordonnées
d'une psychologue finalement je te suis
je ne suis pas allée voir et par chance
le lendemain je suis allée sur les
réseaux sociaux de la ville de Poissy et
j'ai trouvé un programme sur les trois
arches dans le cadre rose justement
voilà l'année dernière et
je me suis dit waouh c'est ma chance en
fait ça représentait tout ce dont
j'avais besoin à ce moment là donc des
soins des soins sociaux esthétiques pour
réapprendre à se maquiller à reprendre
confiance en moi
il y avait de l'activité qu'adapter moi
qui ne faisait plus rien qui avait plus
d'énergie pour rien ben voilà j'ai
trouvé ça avec un personnel encadrant
il y a tellement de choses qui ont été
faites pour moi que je remercierai
jamais assez les trois arches pour ça et
j'ai fait aussi l'atelier de sophrologie
voilà pendant pendant
longtemps voilà c'est très très
important parce que ça m'a permis de
d'avoir un personnel encadrant qui est à
l'écoute des patients et puis j'ai pu
trouver aussi d'autres patientes avec
moi qui ont su me comprendre et c'est
vraiment important cette solidarité
cette écoute cette bienveillance on peut
avoir au sein des trois arches et voilà
ça vous a aidé à sortir de l'isolement
et le mot important c'est la confiance
ça vous a aidé à reprendre confiance
est-ce que vous dites oui oui tout à
fait ça a été vraiment un vrai tremplin
pour moi
revoir aussi une psychologue aussi ça
m'a permis aussi de libérer aussi ma
parole il y a des groupes de parole
aussi bon j'ai pu bénéficier voilà j'ai
fait tout ce que j'avais pu voilà tout
ce dont j'avais besoin j'ai pu le faire
et ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup aidé j'ai
fait l'atelier pour le retour à l'emploi
alors que au moment où je l'ai fait je
n'étais vraiment pas en état de
reprendre le travail je me posais
beaucoup de questions sur la suite et si
vous êtes arrêté depuis décembre 2020
c'est bien ça c'est ça et j'ai pu
reprendre en fait confiance en moi grâce
aux ateliers et j'ai pu reprendre
effectivement en temps partiel
thérapeutique depuis début juin la
pollution lumineuse est une des
principales causes de la disparition des
insectes puisqu'elle fragilise des
équilibres biologiques des écosystèmes
l'éclairage c'est aussi le deuxième
poste d'investissement dans les communes
de France métropolitaine autre chose
quand on lève les yeux au ciel
malheureusement on distingue plus qu'une
vingtaine d'étoiles mais vous avez
peut-être déjà fait l'expérience en
campagne loin des villes on peut en
observer jusqu'à plus d'un millier donc
voilà c'est c'est beaucoup plus
restreint et enfin l'Académie nationale
de médecine a également demandé à
classer l'exposition à la lumière de la
nuit dans la liste des agents
perturbateurs endocrin responsable par
exemple des troubles du sommeil mais
c'est vrai qu'on peut même observer le
signal à l'oreillette voilà je le dis et
je suis franc dans cette émission des
fois on peut même distinguer l'ISS
lorsque le ciel est dégagé et c'est vrai
que quand on se trouve en ville bah
c'est un peu difficile effectivement
blanche à la place des étoiles on est
désormais à 258 jours si je ne m'abuse
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 avec
plusieurs épreuves qui vont être
accueillis sur le territoire des
Yvelines alors je sais que Mathilde on
vous verra pas forcément du côté du vélo
drone en 2024 venez une passion plutôt
pour les sports équestres mais à
Versailles il y aura des sports
équestres qui seront qui se dérouleront
à Versailles
je pense que ça va être magnifique de
d'installer ses jeux équestres à
Versailles au coeur du jardin ça va être
vraiment grandiose
donc on aura un super panorama pour pour
ces JO toutes les épreuves parce qu'il y
aura le dressage le saut d'obstacle
enfin le Jumping le cross avec le
concours complet et je crois qu'il y a
même des peut-être des épreuves
d'endurance aussi donc ça va être enfin
pour une passionné comme moi ça va être
génial le passionné de sport que je suis
vous êtes également on l'attend aussi
avec impatience parce que dans une vie
on va peut-être le vivre qu'une fois
est-ce qu'il y a un engouement pour vous
Gabriel Céline autour de cet événement
Gabriel c'est une fierté d'avoir des
épreuves juste à côté de chez nous donc
oui on a hâte de les découvrir
mais pareil mais je pense que
l'équitation c'est ce qui retient le
plus mon attention aussi de tout de tous
les sports proposés
il y a plusieurs épreuves il y aura le
VTT sur la colline d'Élancourt le BMX
autour du Vélodrome national le golf au
Golf National de 50 ans en Yvelines on a
même appris que le marathon des JO
allait passer pour on est parti en tout
cas dans les Yvelines donc il y aura de
quoi se mettre sous la dent pour pour
2024 Fanny cauchoisne se met en
condition cette cycliste morpienne de 21
ans va participer cette semaine au
championnat du monde de cyclisme sur
piste 2022 au Vélodrome national de 50
ans en Yvelines spécialiste de la course
au point la 13e mondiale va courir sous
les couleurs du Laos un choix de cœur
mon arrière-grand-mère est là au ciel et
elle est venue vivre en France après et
j'ai beaucoup d'attaches pour la famille
et je voulais représenter les couleurs
de mes origines avec le Laos depuis
officiellement deux ans fanny a déjà
participé à plusieurs compétitions dont
les championnats asiatiques en juin
dernier une carrière internationale qui
se fait loin de l'équipe de France je
n'ai jamais été contacté par l'équipe de
France et comme j'arrivais à un âge où
il fallait que je décide si vraiment je
voulais faire du haut niveau ou pas j'ai
fait le choix de représenter Laos lors
de ces Championnats du monde de cyclisme
surpiste 2022 Fanny ne se sentira pas
dépaysé la jeune athlète s'entraîne
régulièrement sur des créneaux tout
public dans la structure située à
quelques kilomètres de chez elle ici la
sportive à ses repères je pense que
c'est un léger ère à rapport à d'autres
nations
si donc oui je pense que ça peut être un
avantage par rapport à certaines
personnes pendant ce rendez-vous yvelin
à la piste selon représentant de son
pays partagéa son box avec l'équipe
d'Algérie à domicile à Laura à cœur de
briller devant son public en finissant
le plus haut possible sa course est
programmée ce dimanche 16 octobre il est
venu le temps non pas des cathédrales
dans cette émission même s'il sera
question de Moyen-Âge dans un instant
mais de la première chronique en plateau
sur le plateau de TV 78 de Gabriel
Gontier ça va pas trop de pression pour
pour cette première chronique vous allez
nous parler des idées de sortie du
week-end en tout cas votre sélection des
idées de sortie du week-end et vous
commencez par le festival de la BD de
buxe un rendez-vous classique chaque
année à l'automne et ça revient pour une
29e édition tout à fait Grégory cette
année encore le festival accueille une
cinquantaine d'auteurs adultes jeunesse
mais aussi français et internationaux au
programme du week-end des dédicaces des
rencontres avec les auteurs des
expositions et des animations une fois
encore les petits et grands vont pouvoir
retrouver leur personnage préféré oui
cette année on retrouve Spirou prof
Yakari et bien d'autres de quoi faire le
bonheur des passionnés de BD je pense
de BD
je vous pose pas la question ce que vous
aviez déjà donné quelques éléments de
réponse mardi dans le 7 août mais c'est
Mathilde si vous avez posé la question
donc on va lui poser la question vos
personnages préférés alors moi c'est une
BD peu connue en fait ça s'appelle Julie
Clerc Cécile c'est une BD belge et voilà
c'est une BD peu connu mais que
j'adorais lire quand j'étais plus jeune
c'est l'histoire de trois jeunes femmes
donc la fête de la BD ça se passe ce
week-end du côté de Buc alors c'est tout
aussi immersif c'est à Châteaufort cette
fois-ci avec aussi un rendez-vous
traditionnel c'est la foire médiévale
c'est ce weekend oui complètement
traditionnel on peut le dire c'est la
36e édition de la foire de Châteaufort
en immersion les visiteurs seront
projetés des siècles en arrière pour
retrouver l'ambiance du Moyen-Âge avec
des décors de rue des activités des
moyens de se restaurer aussi à la
manière de l'époque alors prévoyez votre
meilleur costume Grégory présenter y
aller ce week-end ça devrait passer
peut-être ça non mais costume plutôt
médiéval plutôt médiéval avec peut-être
une armure à prévoir pour cette foire
médiévale pour les plus téméraires c'est
pas forcément mon cas il y a le musée
Maurice Denis qui propose une Murder
Party c'est samedi soir de quoi
sera-t-il question c'est ça le musée
vous propose d'enfiler cette fois votre
casquette de détective pour résoudre
tenez-vous bien une enquête criminelle
les skate Game vous plonge alors dans
une soirée tragique des années 1875 où
l'autre de la soirée Charles bondoy va
subitement être assassiné et ça ça se
passe au sein même du musée c'est ça
c'est ce qui rend l'expérience assez
impressionnante et immersive le jeu
prend place au sein même des salles
d'exposition dans un décor aménagé pour
l'occasion est-ce que c'est accessible à
tous alors pour vous pas de souci
Grégory en revanche c'est déconseillé
pour les moins de 15 ans un autre
événement à retenir peut-être ce weekend
pour terminer oui dans le cadre de la
Semaine du Goût samedi et dimanche un
parcours du goût est organisé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est ouvert au
grand public le salon donne lieu à un
concours culinaire qui est destiné à des
jeunes pris en charge dans le cadre de
la PJJ alors la PJJ c'est la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse l'objectif
Grégory ici c'est de favoriser
l'insertion de ces gènes à l'occasion de
cet événement d'ailleurs le garde des
sceaux et ce soir ce jeudi soir dans les
Yvelines tout à fait le ministre de la
Justice
Eric Dupont-Moretti seront ce soir à
Versailles pour plus signé par non
plusieurs conventions notamment une avec
le CFA Médéric et la maison Ladurée pour
prévoir l'accueil des jeunes de la PGJ
en stage et en contrat d'apprentissage
festival de la BD semaine du groupe
hôtel faites votre choix Mathilde
sont assez tentants
je dirais j'irai un peu moins à la mer
de repartie j'avoue tout ce qui est
horreur
fait sensation au sein de la rédaction
si je puis dire tout le monde en a parlé
cet après-midi on a déjà des expériences
et c'est vrai que
la foire médiévale peut-être ce weekend
et du côté de château fort merci Gabriel
c'est très bien merci beaucoup pour pour
ces idées de sortie alors 61 on est
parti en catastrophe d'Alger où je suis
né donc et quand j'ai vu ces images
enfin la télévision
l'exode des
les Ukrainiens moi ça m'a beaucoup fait
rappeler mon enfance où j'avais 14 ans
on est parti en catastrophe voilà tout
ça je me suis dit moi mon petit niveau
de musicien il faut que je fasse quelque
chose plus de 60 000 ouais il y a plus
de 60 minutes craignant qui sont arrivés
en France d'après le gouvernement entre
février septembre 2022 en plus de ça on
voit que le conflit reprend de l'ampleur
en Ukraine avec des bombardements aussi
qui se font de plus en plus présents en
Ukraine c'est important de pas les
oublier les Ukrainiens de ne pas oublier
exactement parce que je me rends compte
qu'il y a actuellement un baisse
d'intérêt je pense pour ces réfugiés
Ukrainiens là je veux absolument faire
quelque chose là on a décidé j'ai eu
étant moi-même président de violence
club des Essarts-le-Roi j'ai contacté
les Lions Club de des Yvelines et tout
le monde a répondu présent et
regarde en tout 22 clubs qui ont accepté
de participer avec moi dans cette action
et ça j'en suis tellement heureux de
répondre
5 jours exceptionnels ingrégory et 5
jours où il y a eu des médailles
françaises il y a eu des records il y
avait 51 pays qui était présent donc oui
c'est du travail mais c'est avant tout
du plaisir Nicolas gandry également
bonsoir bonsoir qui a été présent sur
quelques soirées également au Vélodrome
on reviendra avec vous forcément sur la
victoire ce titre exceptionnel de
Mathilde gros ça a ouvert d'ailleurs le
compteur des titres pour l'équipe de
France sur ces Mondiaux oui puis des
émotions comme on aime en vivre et comme
le seul le sport peut refaire vivre et
on viendra sur cette famille et la
famille gros qui soutient à chaque
compétition sa fille sa petite fille
voir sa nièce Mathilde gros qui a été
championne du monde de la vitesse
individuelle
51 délégations 420 athlètes 22 titres
décernés sur cinq jours de compétition
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur pistes ont
pris fin hier à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines coup d'oeil au
tableau des médailles avec les Pays-Bas
qui a terminé en tête avec quatre
médailles d'or tout comme lit tout comme
l'Italie qui est deuxième mais avec 10
médailles au total 4 en argent de en
bronze la France elle termine à la
troisième place execo avec cette
médaille trois en or trois en argent et
un bronze en 2015 il y avait également
eu cette médailles mais cinq titres au
total de manière générale Jean-Michel
richefort avant qu'on vienne sur les
résultats précis des Français est-ce que
vous diriez que c'est mondiaux 2022 sont
un bon crus oui c'est mondiaux sont
forcément un bon crus l'équipe de France
était quand même attendu il est
difficile de transformer de scorer à
domicile et bon dans l'ensemble je pense
qu'on a eu une très belle équipe de
France avec avec des jeunes c'est pas
forcément ce
qu'on attendait qu'on attendait et c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle mais pour
certains mais dans l'ensemble oui ça a
été un bon cru vous qui avez vécu
Michael les Mondiaux en 2015 ou des
alliés couverts déjà pour tv78 c'est
mondiaux 2022 si vous faites le
comparatif en terme de résultats en
terme de résultat on parlera de
l'événement après en terme de résultat
en 2015 c'est 5 médailles d'or et 2 de
bronze là c'est trois médailles d'or 3
médailles d'argent et une de Bron
toujours 7 au total exactement donc
c'est forcément pour moi moins bien
parce que avec 5 médailles d'or la
France avait surperformé en 2015 là
c'est quand même pas mal 3 médailles
d'or mais un peu moins bien qu'en 2015
oui mais le débat est lancé cinq
médailles dans les disciplines
olympiques et ça c'est très important
parce que nous vient pas que l'objectif
majeur c'est 2024 à domicile et ces cinq
médailles sont très très encourageantes
pour la direction technique nationale
pour Christophe Manal DTN et ça il faut
le souligner parce que les disciplines
olympiques se sont quand même les
disciplines où il est le plus difficile
d'aller chercher les podiums et les
médailles 23 ans et on le disait celle
qui a ouvert le compteur des médailles
d'or pas le compteur des médailles mais
le compteur des médailles d'or sur ces
mondiaux avec une victoire flamboyante à
la vitesse individuelle c'était vendredi
sacré championne du monde Jean-Michel le
rappelait devant les deux Allemands
d'Emma Insee et les associés Friedrich
premier sacre mondial dans l'absolu
également pour la jeune pistarde écoutez
sa réaction
un rêve chanter la marseillais devant
mon public devant sur ma piste dans
notre Vélodrome enfin nous toute
l'équipe de France on s'entraîne ici
donc c'est pour tous les autres athlètes
pour tout le staff pour la fédé c'est
vraiment ouais c'est pour eux quoi c'est
top c'est je pouvais pas ramener mieux
ce soir
qui a sonné un peu le réveil français
sur c'est mon lieu de piste tout à fait
après Jean-Michel elle est à l'avancée
masquée sur ses championnats du monde
avec pas donné d'objectifs particuliers
pour pour Mathilde de gros mais il
fallait qu'à un moment un autre elle
gagne c'était là dans ce domaine
national de 50 ans en Yvelines elle
avait échoué aux Jeux Olympiques on
l'attendait beaucoup on l'annonce comme
la future pépite du cyclisme français
elle a commencé le cyclisme très tard 16
17 ans était venu du basketball c'est
testé sur sur un vélo un jour on lui a
dit tu as du talent lance-toi sur le
cyclisme sur piste j'ai dit du sport
finalement j'ai mis du sport exactement
finalement elle performe elle performait
pas au niveau nouveau mondial pour
l'instant elle a fait quelques titres
notamment européens des titres français
également mais au niveau mondial pour
l'instant ça coincé un peu et là on sent
qu'il y a peut-être eu le déclic pour
Mathilde de gros mais on sent peut-être
en avant après mon Dieu on va parler de
Mathilde de gros et du clan gros avec
Nicolas on a l'impression qu'il y aura
un avant et un après peut-être que c'est
une nouvelle mative de gros là qui est
lancée tout droit vers ces certainement
mais c'est le fruit d'un travail acharné
pour avoir été témoin de plusieurs
séances d'entraînement notamment avec
Grégory Baugé je pense que là le travail
à un moment donné ou un autre paix et là
elle a pris une dimension sans aucun
doute une dimension supplémentaire un
peu dans sa manière d'appréhender chaque
course on voit qu'elle avait un visage
assez fermé il y a des photos qui sont
assez impressionnantes sur les réseaux
sociaux où on la voit juste avant la
course chercher le regard de ses
adversaires du regard il est
exceptionnel et on voit qu'elle était
beaucoup plus déterminée
à se plaquer limite de faire un miniaca
quoi le se claquer les cuisses se
claquer les pectoraux c'est on voyait
plus de tête détermination je sais pas
votre avis Jean-Michel oui absolument
très rapidement et la prix la prime
dimension effectivement et là surtout en
sprint où il faut prendre l'ascendant
sur l'adversaire même avant le match et
je pense qu'il y a une grosse part de
bluff aussi d'habitude c'est elle qui
subissait le bluff des adversaires et là
finalement c'est elle qui a pris
l'ascendant tout simplement les cons on
s'en souvient une demi-finale qui s'est
joué à la belle d'ailleurs on aurait pu
croire que ça aurait pu la fatiguer pour
la finale il n'en a pas été ainsi et
Mathilde de gros c'est imposé en vitesse
individuelle première médaille d'or
française il y en a eu trois en tout on
va parler des autres médailles d'or dans
un instant mais vendredi Nicolas vous
avez suivi avec plus d'attention cette
course de Mathilde de gros en vitesse
individuelle et aux côtés de sa famille
qui était présente en nombre en tribunes
jusqu'à son sacre et à la remise de la
médaille d'or effectivement Grégory
alors je vous ai dit j'étais dans la
zone au début au niveau des premières
demi-finales et puis deuxième
demi-finale je suis allé voir la famille
qui était en tribune et je vais
commencer par cette séquence très forte
Grégory Mathilde gros vient de remporter
sa finale face à l'Allemande Léa Sophie
Frédéric la piste de 23 ans et
championne du monde de vitesse
individuelle elle va rejoindre sa
famille en tribune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce premier best of du 7
8 la suite du mois d'octobre demain même
heure bonne fête sur TV 78
[Musique]